meine these dreht sich um ein maskierter
gekauft hat und jetzt die große
diskussion entstanden ist wie viel
verantwortung geht da eigentlich auch
mit einher und ich glaube wir können
festhalten die großen plattformen die
großen sozialen netzwerke sie tragen
jeden tag mehr dazu bei wie
meinungsbildung auch in unseren
gesellschaften in unseren demokratien
stattfindet deswegen parzellen maske
auch eine sehr große verantwortung an
der stelle der gerecht werden muss das
heißt wir müssen die meinungsfreiheit
schützen und auf der anderen seite ist
das netz eben kein rechtsfreier raum und
für diese ausgewogenheit haben wir uns
auch in der vergangenheit immer
entsprechend eingesetzt da geht es eben
einen rechtlichen rahmen auch zu
schaffen und gerade aber auf der
europäischen ebene glaube ich müssen wir
noch mehr tun wir haben phänomene wie
die pigs wir brauchen eher
schnittstellen auch gerade für die
forschung um wirklich auch zu sehen die
entwickeln sich denn überhaupt
meinungsbildung 'nen auf den plattformen
und wir brauchen vor allem im letzten
auch einen guten und fairen wettbewerb
den wir eben bei den sozialen netzwerken
nicht haben und da muss l macht jetzt
auch seinen beitrag als unternehmer an
der stelle mit dazu liefern ja also ich
habe mich doch sehr gewundert dass
twitter verkauft wird für so viel geld
ich halte mal grundsätzlich gar nichts
davon das sind einer hand sich so eine
medienmacht konzentriert das kann nicht
gut sein für die vielfalt in unserem
lande oder sogar weltweit außerdem sind
mir einige doch sehr merkwürdige zitate
des herrn masken anderen zusammenhang
bekannt um gottes willen ich weiß nicht
ob er der richtige ist um wirklich so
ein unternehmen zu leiten und nach vorne
zu bringen da habe ich große bedenken
bin ich nicht dafür frau aussagen wie
sehen sie das blick auf die
meinungsfreiheit dass herr maske sven
damit hat es ja auch übernahm in die
meinungsfreiheit zu wahren so gut dass
er da ist jetzt erst mal behauptet ist
nun eine seite ich finde dass es
problematisch dass es immer
problematisch wenn
jemand in einem solchen monopolsituation
ist und ich twitter ist ohnehin ein von
mir etwas kritisch begutachtet des
meinungsbildung
platz eine mein name ist ein ort des
hasses ist sie sind nicht ganz falsch
glaube ich mit dieser bezeichnung also
wenn ich twitter drei minuten anguckt
ist mein tag für mich gelaufen dann habe
ich so viel schlechte laune angestaut
dass ich sagen kann wir jemanden
blumenstrauß schenken dass wir es also
gut aber ich glaube jetzt nicht das aber
macht das besser macht erst ein paar
überlegungen wie er da strukturen
verändern will aber dass das was ich ja
immer glaube ist das monopol richtigen
hingeben muss dass es das ist eine
ordnungsbusse struktur geben muss in der
sich nicht zu viel macht und zwar in
diesem fall
monetäre und meinungsmacht
zusammenbringen und dass man da ziemlich
genau hingucken muss also ich bin da
sehr kritisch und sehr ich stelle mir
stehen mit den breiten sehr zu es gibt
ja nicht mal mehr die börsen demokratie
also die abstimmung auf einer
hauptversammlung dass verschiedene
aktionär unterschiedlicher meinung sein
können und dass es darüber an ringen
gibt wie eine solche während solches
unternehmen aufgestellt wird ein
einziger mensch bestimmt wie die
kommunikation über twitter weltweit
läuft das ein völlig unhaltbarer zustand
in den usa gibt es seit jahren eine
diskussion über die zerschlagung die
kartellrechtliche zerschlagung großer
internetkonzerne
und die müsste jetzt wieder aufleben die
die sport vor sich hin die usa haben das
schon mal gemacht die haben standard all
den den den monopolisten des ölgeschäfts
zerschlagen in verschiedene große immer
noch große ölkonzerne und twitter darf
nicht in der hand eines einzelnen mannes
bleiben er hat ja etwas dunkel
angekündigt er wolle die
meinungsfreiheit sogar verbreitern da
gibt es jetzt mutmaßung die mine hat das
land aktuell auf twitter muss ich sagen
mit den warnhinweisen unsere sachen aus
gewähren wenn twitter ist aktuell jetzt
auch nicht die oase der meinungsfreiheit
ja aber das wollen wir der nase von
rechtsradikalen und und hetzern wollen
wir auch nicht haben oder also
radikalität sagt nicht natürlich nicht
was du an bord wird weil ich mich nicht
den ganzen tag mit rechtsradikalen
hetzern rum
die wird ihm wird den würde ich da
begegnen also jedenfalls ein mann
hier wo die grenzen der meinungsfreiheit
verlaufen das geht überhaupt nicht
sondern dann muss man eben eine
konkurrenz zwischen verschiedenen
diensten herstellen und die müssen in
irgend einer form von kollektiven händen
sein und sei es der die kollektive
weisheit der börse gibt hoc kammer kann
man vielleicht auch sagen dass die
kritiker sich meine der mann war im
april letzten jahres der reichste mann
zum beispiel war er schon der welt das
ist ja mal sein vermögen hängt immer ein
bisschen vom tesla aktienkurs ab aber er
hat ja sogar schon jeff bezos einmal
überrannt gehabt ist ein mass geht es
nicht vielleicht einfach der visionär
denn die welt brauche ich meine tesla
automobil dass alle jetzt noch twitter
ist er vielleicht der mächtigste mann
der welt jetzt auf jeden fall ein
mächtiger mann er ist auch ein
beeindruckender unternehmer und trotzdem
stimme ich schon zu es ist wirklich sehr
sehr viel macht jetzt in der hand einer
person es wird aber auch nicht besser
wenn wir zum beispiel die
eigentümerstruktur von facebook sehen da
gibt es auch aktionäre ob das jetzt so
viel demokratischer ist an der stelle
würde ich mal ein fragezeichen
dransetzen und deswegen brauchen wir
neben der verantwortung die allem us
kids auf der einen seite hat wir
brauchen auch klare spielregeln der
politik vor allem auf der europäischen
ebene und es ist ob jetzt dann gleich
sagen muss wir müssen die konzerne
zerschlagen würde ich sagen nein aber
wir brauchen zumindest ein
funktionierendes kartell und
wettbewerbsrecht das wirklich auch
messenger zb interoperabel funktionieren
weil das problem ist eben wir haben
monopole in diesen bereichen und die
kunden und nutzer können sich ja gar
nicht aussuchen sie sind am ende zum
gewissen grad darauf angewiesen weil wir
eben nur diesen diese entsprechenden
angeht also ich wirklich läuft auch
laufen ständig gegen die cdu wenn in der
in den usa dem stammland des
kapitalismus wesentliche kräfte im
kongress dafür sind diese internetriesen
zu zerschlagen
dann sind die ja linker als die cdu hier
wo gibt es denn so was sie wollen die
nicht zerschlagen
man redet aber dem vorschlag eines
schlager schlagen heißt nicht ändern das
ist ja unsinn die anlagen sind ex
ölkonzern hat gewonnen alle privatisiert
und
regulierungen dann gebe ich doch noch
mal hierhin machen dass ihm allein
sitzen den ball hin zum doppel zu machen
was für regulierungen könnte man dann
brauchen regulierung natürlich auf
europäischer ebene also weltweit wird
das nicht funktionieren das heißt es
muss eigentlich beschränkt sein wie viel
prozent eine person oder eine gruppe von
personen an teilhaben können einem
unternehmen da kann man quoren sagen
also nicht über 75 prozent oder nicht
über 50 das wäre so eine möglichkeit was
man machen könnte auf europäischer ebene
also in deutschland alleine nutzt das ja
eine runde überhaupt nichts und darauf
wenn man sogar weltweit darauf verstehen
könnte wäre das sehr gut noch einmal ich
finde es sehr bedenklich diese macht in
einer hand und dann auch noch finde ich
ihn auch etwas zwielichtig aber gut das
ist ja nun eine meinung ich weiß denn
ich komme immer darauf an wie es ist ja
aber ich meine ist müssen rechtliche
grenzen gesetzt werden so wie sie das
auch gesagt haben das ist der richtige
weg wahrscheinlich die anteilseigener
schafft zu begrenzen und trotzdem song
wie viel macht hat man denn wenn man
jetzt twitter kaufen wie groß ist denn
die macht der sozialen medien letztlich
spielt twitter ja auch sr eine plattform
auf der die beteiligten die sich dort
anmelden auch eine gewisse rolle spielen
das heißt dass wir alle machen könnten
wäre unser twitter konto abzubestellen
ich glaube das würde insgesamt zu einer
allgemeinen beruhigung beitragen wäre
richtig ja oder da hätten wir könnten
wir alle wieder besser schlafen wir
hätten mehr spaß wir könnten den
frühling viel besser genießen das wäre
jetzt eine zivilgesellschaftliche
möglichkeit ansonsten natürlich auf der
seite das natürlich muss das
gesetzlich und also politische
strukturen geschaffen werden in denen
ist eine solche macht kumulation nicht
geben kann weil das ist das ist schon
sehr gefährlich wir haben das ist zwar
nicht der eigner von twitter web sich
teilweise auf gespielt dann hat trump
was er durch twitter ausgelöst hat jetzt
für richtig dass er gesperrt wurde von
twitter donald trump ja also in dem fall
halte ich es für richtig das ist auch
nicht mal im rahmen der meinungsfreiheit
oder nicht meinungsfreiheit sondern da
ist jemand der tatsächlich
die aufstände die wir am 6 januar
gesehen haben
geschürt hat und der natürlich durch
sein amt oder dann ex amt eine so große
anhängerschaft hatte dass er
brandgefährlich war in dieser in dieser
blase die ja keine blase male bewiesen
dann den ganzen globus umfassende blase
und da finde ich ist es im rahmen des
der sicherheit dass wir jemand da nicht
viel über leib